Now it's true, there really is no right or wrong
answer to this question. This is a real life decision
that you'd have to make as a director of clinical
operations. Now after speaking with the director of clinical operations that
we interviewed. She said that she would probably go with
the first answer. And she said that the reason is
because the information is incredibly valuable. And she could add
an early safety review to the very beginning of the study
so that as soon as they begin to
notice anything that might be significant or severe,
they could get the person off the drug.
However, she also mentioned that you could pick
the second answer and probably find a good
justification for that too. Which one did you
pick? Why don't you go to the forums and see what your class mates think too.